how do you deal with depression man
because a lot of people they they keep
it inside and then you know they end up
turning to unhealthy [ __ ] some people
like did you go to therapy did you
um for me
I mean played a lot more video games
um but that's what Vlad said on Twitter
that went viral he said people who play
a certain amount of video games
like if you play more than like four
hours a day or something he said it's a
form of depression
um what does he know does he play video
games I I don't know I'm just happy you
know what it went viral I don't know but
so you you kind of dived into the video
games a lot more
um yeah yeah that's what I do
um I try to read as much as I can but
like you know other than that man I just
try to get off of the fake World which
is like you know Instagram and social
media disconnect you know there's a
point where I didn't have Instagram for
like five months or something like that
I was just were you happier when you
didn't I was super happy yeah because I
didn't think about it or even care you
know um
than Twitter like I would keep it on a
certain device so if I ever wanted to
use it I had to go get this device like
a laptop actually and then use my laptop
to get on Twitter you know
um so just like little things like that
to help me not think about certain stuff
but um yeah I think like when you're
in our industry like it's really easy to
kind of like get wrapped up in like
comparing yourself to your peers all the
time right it's like you open your phone
and you like and that somehow that kind
of
[ __ ] with what you think your
self-worth is yeah it does that yeah and
then like you know I can only imagine
you you got this super microphone on
Twitter and IG of people leaving
comments tweeting at you whether it's
good or bad if you see it even if you
don't think you take it in
subconsciously you take that [ __ ] in you
know yeah exactly you know I mean yeah
definitely subconsciously but uh I don't
even care these days it's just funny
like when I see people who just who just
say just the most negative things like I
just like I'll get messages sometimes
with DM a dude just going in going crazy
like yo you fell off so bad I used to be
a fan of you but not anymore and I'll
just be like I love you bro well first
of all you didn't I'd like to point out
we only have two albums okay yeah that's
or is it three it's three three now you
try the third one in 2020 yeah yeah but
like yo you like listen man yeah you're
[ __ ] you're Bryson tiller don't
forget it bro no I appreciate it no but
it don't phase me it used to phase me
don't get me wrong it used to phase me a
lot but now I just like I just let them
know that I love him because like if
you're gonna type this message up and
take all this time to type this mess up
you really actually love me because was
that would you say that you would like
you used to like you used to like really
let that [ __ ] get to you yeah definitely
definitely got to me yeah for sure I
think that's like the gift I think you
just got to push through that [ __ ] man
because a lot of the great artists have
gone through that when you got a [ __ ]
classic album The Kicks kicks off your
career
[ __ ] Snoop Dogg man that like he'd
put out the dog father and I think 96
his first time was doggy style don't
give a [ __ ] about the dog father because
it wasn't doggy style yeah I just think
you just gotta just keep dropping bro
keep going because